This video is to give you more
examples of Fourier series.
I'll start with a
function that's odd.
My odd function means that
on the left side of 0,
I get the negative of what I
have on the right side of 0.
F at minus x is minus f of x.
And it's the sine
function that's odd.
The cosine function is even, and
we will have no cosines here.
All the integrals
that involve cosines
will tell us 0 for
the coefficients AN.
What we'll get is
the B coefficients,
the sine functions.
So you see that I chose a simple
odd function, minus 1 or 1,
which would give a square
wave if I continue it on.
It will go down, up, down,
up in a square wave pattern.
And I'm going to express
that as a combination
of sine functions, smooth waves.
And here was the
formula from last time
for the coefficients
bk, except now I'm
only integrating over
half, over the zero
to pi part of the
interval, so I double it.
So that's an odd function,
that's an odd function.
When I multiply them, I
have an even function.
And the integral
from minus pi to 0
is just the same as the
integral from 0 to pi.
So I'll do only 0 to
pi and multiply by 2.
But my function on 0 to pi is 1.
My nice square wave
is just plus 1 there,
so I'm just
integrating sine kx dx.
We can do this.
It's minus cosine kx
divided by k, right?
That's the integral with
the 2 over pi factor.
Now I have to put
in pi and 0 and put
in the limits of integration
and get the answer.
So what do I get?
I get 2 over pi.
For k equal 1, I think
I get-- so k is 1,
the denominator will be 1, and
I think the numerator is 2.
Yes, when k is 0, I get yeah.
When k is 1, I get 2.
When k is 2, so
this is 4 over pi,
I figured out as the
first coefficient.
The coefficient b1 is 4 over pi.
The coefficient b2, now if I
take k equal to 2, I have a 2
down below.
But above, I have a 0
because the cosine of 2 pi
is the same as the cosine of 0.
When I subtract I get
nothing, so that's 0.
Now I go to k equals 3.
So the k equals 3
will come down here.
And now when k is 3, it turns
out I get-- they don't cancel,
they reinforce.
I get another 2.
Good if you do these.
And when k is 4,
I get a 0 again.
You see the pattern?
The pattern for the integrals
is the k is going 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
This part gives me a 2 or
a 0 or a 2 or a 0 in order.
If you check that,
you'll get it.
So I see that now for this
function, which is better
than the delta function also.
It's not very smooth.
It has jumps.
It's a jump function,
a step function.
I see some decay,
some slow decay,
in the Fourier coefficients.
This factor k is growing so
the numbers are going to 0,
but not very fast.
Not very fast.
Because my function
is not very smooth.
So now you see-- so if
I use those numbers,
I'm saying that the square wave,
this function, the minus 1 to 1
function, is equal
to, let's see.
I might as well take
that 4 over pi times 1.
So that's 1 sine x, 0, sine 2x's
then 4 over pi sine 3x's, but
with this guy there's
a 3, 0 sine 4x's,
sine 5x comes in
over 5, and so on.
That's a kind of nice example.
It turns out that we have
just the odd frequencies 1, 3,
5 in the square wave and
they're multiplied by 4 over pi
and they're divided by the
frequency, so that's the decay.
There is an odd function.
Why don't I integrate
that function?
If I want to get
an even function
to show you an even
example, I'll just
integrate that square wave.
When I integrate it square
wave, it'll be even.
Maybe I'll start the integral
at 0, then it goes up at 1.
And here the integral is
negative, so it's coming down.
So you see it's a-- what am I
going to call this function?
Sort of a repeating
ramp function.
It's a ramp down and then
up, down and then up.
But of course from minus pi to
pi, that's where I'm looking.
I'm looking between
minus pi and pi.
And I see that function is even.
And what does even mean?
That means that my
function at minus--
there is minus x-- is the
same as the value at x.
And what that means for a
Fourier series is cosine.
Even functions only
have cosine terms.
And of course, since
I've just integrated,
I might as well just
integrate that series.
So this is this ramp, this
repeating ramp function,
is going to be 4 over pi.
I could figure out the
cosine coefficients,
the a's, patiently.
But why should I do that
when I can just integrate?
So the integral of
sine x will be minus
is the integral of
sine x, is minus cosine
x, so I'll put the minus
there, cosine x over 1 I guess.
Now what's the integral of this?
The integral of sine 3x
is a cosine 3x over 3.
And there's another
3 and there's
a minus sign, which I've got.
So I think it's cosine
of 3x over 3 squared,
because I have one 3
there and I get another 3
from the integration.
And similarly here,
when I integrate sine 5x
I get cos 5x with a 5.
And then I already had
one 5, so 5 squared.
So there you go.
[LAUGHTER]
There's something in freshman
calculus which I totally
forgot, the constant term.
So there is a constant term,
the average value, that a0.
I've only found
the a1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I haven't found the a0, and that
would be the average of that.
I don't know, what's the
average of this function?
Its goes from 0 up
to pi and it seems
like it's pretty-- I didn't
draw it well, but half way.
I think probably its average
is about pi over 2, right?
Let's hope that's right.
So let me sneak in the
constant term here.
The ramp is, I think I have
a constant term is pi over 2.
That's the average value.
It would come from the
formula and those-- well,
what do you see now?
That's the other example
I wanted you to see.
You see a faster drop off.
1, 9, 25, 49, whatever.
It's dropping off
with k squared.
And the reason it drops
off faster than this one
is that it's smoother.
This function has corners.
This function has jumps.
So a jump is one level
more rough, more word
noisy than a ramp function.
The smoother function
has faster decay.
Smooth-- let me
write those words--
smooth function connects
with faster decay.
Faster drop off of the
Fourier coefficient.
It means that the Fourier
series is much more useful.
Fourier series is really
terrific for functions
that are smooth because then you
only need to keep a few terms.
For functions that have
jumps or delta functions,
you have to keep
many, many terms
and the Fourier
series calculation
is much more difficult.
So that's the second example.
Let's see, what
more shall I say?
We learned something
about integrating
and taking the
derivative so let me
end with just two basic rules.
Two basic rules.
So the rule for derivatives.
What's the Fourier
series of df dx?
And the second will
be the rule for shift.
What's the Fourier series
for f of x minus a shift?
You know that when I change
x to x minus d, all that does
is shift the graph
by a distance d.
That should do something nice
to its Fourier coefficient.
So I'm starting with--
oh, I haven't given you
any practice with
a complex case.
This would be a good time.
Suppose start is f of
x equals the sum of ck,
a complex coefficient e to the
ikx, the complex exponential.
And you'll remember that
sum went from minus infinity
to infinity.
So I have a Fourier series.
I'm imagining I know the
coefficients and I want to say,
what happens if I
take the derivative?
Well, just take the derivative.
You'll have a sum of the
derivative brings down
a factor ik.
So that's the rule.
Simple, but important.
That's why Fourier series
is so great because you
have orthogonality and then
you have this simple rule
with derivatives.
it just brings a factor
ik so the derivative
make sure function noisier and
you have larger coefficients.
And if I do f of
x minus d, so I'll
change x to x minus d, so I'll
see the sum of ck e to the ikx,
e to the minus ikd, right?
I've put in x minus
d instead of x.
And here I see that the Fourier
coefficient for a shifted
function-- so the ck was a
Fourier coefficient for f.
When I shift f, it
multiplies that coefficient
by a phase change.
The magnitude stayed
the same because that's
a number-- everybody recognizes
that as a number of magnitude 1
and just has a phase shift.
Those are two would
rules that show
why you can use Fourier series
in differential equations
and in difference equations.
Thank you.